good morning
it says nine o'clock on my phone so uh
let's get today started welcome I am
very pleased to be here I hope in the
final day so my name is Christine Gorman
I work as a contractor consultant for a
company called cool the market and I
have been working as a developer for
more than 20 years now
and I'm going to talk about something
that I've noticed you know over the
years there's one thing that seems to be
true almost across the board you know
every company that that I you know that
I've been helping out or worked at or
you know or that people talk about
people you know always seems to be
working on the new platform am I right
there's always this new platform you
know so yeah here new platform again you
know like I've been doing this for more
than 20 years now and I'm just starting
to ask some questions here I mean
there's always some poor souls in the
background
who are working on the Legacy system
right you know they're like making
features for users and stuff but all the
cool kids you know we're working on the
new platform and
presumably
you know this the point of a platform
you know it doesn't matter if it's an
I.T platform or an oil platform or
whatever kind of platform a platform
the whole purpose of it is it only has
value in so far as it facilitates the
delivery of the stuff that actually
matters you know the platform itself has
no value so I'm starting to wonder like
when are we actually going to be when
are we going to get to focus on
delivering the value that these
platforms are meant to be you know
giving us you know we are always working
on the platforms this is weird so I mean
it's like Verna are we just not very
good at making platforms since that's
all we seem to be doing or or or maybe
maybe we are maybe I'm looking at this
from the wrong angle you know it's
important to you know very often when
you think you see a problem you know
you're just not seeing the real purpose
here so we need to look at this from
different angles and see what why are we
always building these platforms and who
are they for and and like what are we
really achieving here
and very often when I bring up this you
know I you know I work Hands-On with
code so often you know when I bring up
these kind of systemic issues and I'm
I'm very annoying that way I'm always
bringing up these issues
um I'm told that yeah Christine you just
don't you don't see the full picture
you're you're just you're just
developing you're a developer kind of on
the floor you don't see the big picture
that's why you don't understand and
you know and that is very important I
think it's really important to be aware
of your blind spots but I I just love
this quote here you know those who draw
landscapes Place themselves Below in the
plane to contemplate the nature of the
mountain you know if you want to really
understand and see the mountain you
can't be on the mountain you have to be
on the ground to even see the mountain
in the first place and likewise you know
in order to contemplate the planes they
Place themselves upon high mountains so
I mean yes it is true that as you know
as a mere developer I don't I some very
often lack the big picture but vice
versa is also true when you are standing
up top and have the big picture you lack
you know the uh how imposing the
mountain you're on top possibly is you
know so it's really you know this goes
both ways having you really need to
listen every perspective is important
here and everyone has their blind spots
so of all things this is a quote from
Machiavelli which is a uh and again I
try to always expose myself to texts and
and works of people I I you know have no
expectation of agreeing with because I
think it's it is really important to
understand all the all the points of
view and uh and again here I you know I
read the prince by Nicolo Machiavelli
and hey I got a good quote out of it
um so I recommend everyone really you
know try to expose yourself to
uncomfortable things that you have no
intention of agreeing with or or
whatever you might be surprised anyway
but another thing I love about this
image you know because here you have
someone who's you know standing on top
of the mountain to you know really get a
good overview
um but they're not getting a good
overview are they because there's a
cloud cover here there are clouds in the
way yeah so even if you have uh you have
the vantage point where you could you
know see the big picture in fact you
don't after all and in a corporate
setting this you know Cloud layer is uh
you know often consists of you know
middle management bureaucracy and I.T
you know we are here this is us you know
we are not you know the I.T department
or whatever we are not the ones making
strategic business decisions nor are we
the users of the software that we're
making we're this layer in between uh
and we have our own agendas and our own
you know wishes and desires and ideas of
what we want so when we talk about you
know success you know who are we who are
we who are we talking about here what is
a success for one group might not be a
success for someone else you know again
who are we talking about here who are
these platforms for in this case
I mean are we trying to you know impress
as a shareholder value is that the thing
I mean this is capitalism you know are
we is our goal to improve business
profits is that what we're up to you
know for the for the business
administration again they are on top of
the mountain they need this you know
they need to understand the vastness of
what's going on they need easy to
understand you know graphs and kpis and
stuff so that they can make decisions
across the board that will make sense
they don't have the capacity to go in
and look at the details in every little
bit they need a good kind of overall
perspective so I mean that's important
to them again for the project managers
you know their job what they've been you
know taught their field of expertise is
that you need to deliver you know a
package on time and on budget you know
they have a specification and that you
know so that is their motivation a
success for them is have we delivered
what we said we would on time and on
budget yes success when it comes to us
what do we want you know we want cool
text that looks good on our CV right we
want to work on the latest cool amazing
stuff uh that we've learned about at
conferences like this you know we've
seen someone present something cool
they've done or like yes I'm gonna run
home and I'm going to try that and I
want to do that that's what we want to
do I mean let's be honest we just want
we want to work on Cool Tech that's why
we're in this
um
and yeah finally the users what's the
success for them
who cares I mean
we only care about the users if we are
forced to you know and and that might
sound harsh it might sound like I'm just
I'm just trying to provoke people but
like this is sadly very true and if you
want proof look at you know look at
corporate software
where the users are not the ones buying
the software corporate software I'm
talking about any software that is
bought by an organization and then they
tell all their employees right here
here's where you put in your hours that
you've worked this month or or you know
I've just been working in healthcare and
oh my God it is just horrible the kind
of user interfaces they have to deal
with it is appalling
um because again the users don't matter
they don't matter they're not paying
they're not paying for the stuff There's
No Business case here for for really for
for making the user experience great I
mean here this is this is I mean it
would be hilarious if it's not so sad
this is from the local newspaper in the
middle of Norway where they have
followed in Denmark's example actually
Denmark they introduced sunnets platform
I believe which is an epic configuration
thing epic is a big kind of software
platform thing from the US and so they
failed and as soon as platform man has
been a complete disaster for usability
and they also have done this in Finland
in the opportunity it's called there and
it's also a complete disaster and we
spent lots of money everyone hates it so
Norway we're like yes we need to try too
well actually it's funny because they
said you know because we were like but
it didn't work in Denmark it didn't work
in Finland maybe you know there's no no
no but we will learn from their mistakes
that's not how you learn from their
mistakes what we should have learned was
not to do anyway but this is this is
doctors and nurses in Norway's third
largest hospital they are out on the
streets with torches desperately
protesting against the software system
like can we please please please don't
force us to use this I've never seen I
mean this is like you know you cannot be
more clear as a user you know that you
really want change but you know do we
listen yeah we don't care we don't care
this doesn't matter
the users are not the buyers
from a business perspective it doesn't
make sense it doesn't make Financial
sense to focus on a group of people that
are not going to help you make money
after all you need to if you are making
software you need to address the people
making the purchasing decisions which is
why software made where where we all are
the ones getting the software you know
that their usability has to be better
because otherwise we wouldn't use the
stuff but you know if you are selling
stuff to a purchasing department hey
well that's who you need to impress
it's those people
you need to make them happy and I
learned this early I I did um all the
Computing courses I could while I was in
the Norwegian equivalent of high school
and one of my teachers there uh was this
guy who had I think he sold his company
and he was just working as a teacher for
fun so he was doing physics and
Computing and stuff and he told us
stories about his you know his life when
he'd been he'd been working in his
company and um and there was a fun
Software System they'd made I forget
what it does but it you know they'd had
mild success in Norway
um so it sold it to some companies and
and they you know they were doing quite
well and they thought well okay this is
working in Norway let's try to expand
let's go to let's go to Denmark and
Sweden you know Germany England and they
try to see if they could drum up some
interest you know uh abroad and then
yeah you know they weren't really that
successful no one seemed to be that
interested and but then finally after
you know a couple of years they landed a
massive contract in I believe Egypt uh
and I'll never forget my teacher was
like isn't that interesting guys you
know why do you think you know why you
know we thought it would be easier to
sell in countries that are you know more
you know culturally similar to us and
whatever you know why you know why do
you think we were successful you know
that far away from home
that's because we bribed them
that's what I remember from that
Computing course here but but again and
uh he it was not the users he was
talking about you know he they they
bribed the people who were making the
purchasing decisions because of course
that's what matters
um and if we if we talk about like if
you want to maximize the chances of of
really delivering
um you know value for money and making
the right decisions you want to
basically have a complete overlap if you
are making something with your own time
and your own competency and your own
money and you are making things for
yourself then you have the highest
chance of making the right decisions and
getting what you want right a complete
overlap of the user and the buyer and
the uh and the implementer right whereas
what we see at least on corporate
software all too often uh is uh is this
you have the users over here and then
you have the purchasing department and
there you know that it's a completely
different there's no overlap here at all
yeah and then you have the I.T
Department there's no overlap there
either you know this is this is far from
ideal you know and this Venn diagram I
have to thank my colleague Finn for
suggesting that this actually isn't a
Venn diagram
so for non-scandinavians here then means
friend and uven means enemy so this is
more of an enemy diagram than a than a
Venn diagram anyway but all too often
when we then decide to make make a
platform
and that's our Focus all too often we
end up just making a whole nother box
here you have you know the the
purchasing department buys a platform
whatever that might be
um and then you have a whole other group
of of people who will be then using the
the apis from the platform to deliver
something to the users again you know
and this is this is very unfortunate
that you have so many different groups
and everyone has their own motivations
and their own agendas
um yeah yeah so many agendas and that
run completely counter to what anyone
might hope would be a sane way of
approaching uh software development like
for instance you know if you are an I.T
Department you are someone's like cost
center you get your funding from outside
you're not using you're not using you're
not creating software to help yourself
make money you are you know that's the
only thing you do is you do you deliver
stuff to other people and you get a
budget
you know in that case if you're in
charge of that organization should you
use as much time and money as possible
or should you use as little time and
money as possible you know and uh this
should of course not be a real dilemma
we want everyone obviously to try to use
as little time and money as possible
yeah because that makes sense but if but
of course you know if you think about
this realistically and you're going to
press the as much money as possible
every time because you have no Financial
incentives at all to reduce to to you
know start delivering More For Less you
know and this I I you know I've even
heard managers say this out loud you
know like if we start delivering more
they'll cut our budgets this is a real
thing I mean and it's not just in
Computing you know using up your budget
making sure that you don't you know that
you use everything up is super important
this is a real thing in the military my
uh colleagues have told me that there's
a Norwegian Church
like shooting Christmas in or something
where basically you have to make sure
that you're using up you're blowing up
everything you're using up all the ammo
and all the explosives by the end of the
year because otherwise you don't get as
much next year you know and and there's
a whole movement
for managers now called Beyond budgeting
you know which is meant to address this
because this is a big problem actually I
mean you know people who get a fixed
um fixed budgets like this it causes
horrible incentives where you actually
try to use up everything rather than
saving money and I've heard so many
times you know you'll have these annual
things where people like yes we
increased our budgets we got you know x
million more this year this is fantastic
and I'm always thinking well you know
isn't that kind of sad if shouldn't we
be celebrate shouldn't we be celebrating
getting less money because we're more
effective you know I've never heard that
I've never heard anyone celebrate that
so I mean there's a there's a problem
here
um also like efficiency
efficiency things if you try not I I
hear this you know as a developer I'm
always asking like can't I just talk to
the users and just make what they want
you know that would be you know very
efficient but of course then you'll have
a whole layer of of people who are meant
to manage that process who will
potentially feel like they don't have a
job you know so there's a lot of there's
a lot of this going on too where people
are worried about their job security you
know that they they don't want to be you
know they're worried that if you
actually you know save time and money
then ah you know what will I do then I
can just sit and drink coffee all day
yeah so I mean we need to address these
we need we need to be aware of these
things at least and of course you know
everyone knows that you know again like
usability features why on Earth would I
do that you know doing things right
that's going to cost you much you know
so people will consciously go for crappy
Solutions because yeah
um
yeah doing it right will cost you much
money and again for programmers I mean
like there can be a perfectly the users
can be perfectly happy but you know we
we've been to conference we've learned
we want to use a cool new technology we
don't want to work on this old old Tech
stack we don't want to you know we want
to work on the new shiny stuff
um and I think it's kind of sad when it
comes to you know making like business
choices or whatever there's this there's
this um idea I think especially maybe
especially in the US I'm not sure but
certainly you know Western culture seems
to have this idea that you know to be
successful you kind of need to be a
selfish you know and there are
plenty of examples of this of course you
know like Steve Jobs was a notorious
he's like a horrible person uh
impossible to work with but you know he
was successful and we have this idea
that you know you have to kind of be
this ruthless you know maximize your own
uh profits type of person to have
success at all but this
true I mean like you can also be
successful by doing the right thing you
know and and and whenever you say this
uh you're often you know kind of accused
of being oh isn't that oh they're just
so naive and oh so sweet and no you have
to be ruthless like no uh because you
know empathy is something the vast
majority of us have you know we this
this is a human trait there are a few
people who lack empathy and that's you
know sad for them you know the the vast
vast majority of us you know if I make
you smile that's gonna make me happy you
know and being you know trying to
actually do good in the world and being
you know delivering you know things that
actually matter not just to me but to
other people that gives us success on a
whole other level so we can both get
financial success and get the really
good feeling of actually making a
positive difference in the world you
know so this isn't like me being like
naive and oh yeah sweet little girl who
thinks that we can be nice no this
actually makes sense so we should we
should do this and we should um yeah
anyway try to try to think about like
why are we doing this and how can I how
can I actually you know make a
difference not just for myself but you
know in the in the bigger picture so
again what is the right thing for us to
do
well deliver software that makes the
users lives better because I mean that
is the point of software you know we're
not like hopefully we're we're not the
society isn't run by like aliens or AI
or anything like that I mean all
software is made because there is some
kind of human need out there that needs
to be filled I mean that's why we're in
this business in the first place you
know we need to identify what you know
who are the users that will benefit from
what we are making and then we need to
focus on that how do we make sure that
the users are going to be you know their
lives are going to be improved by this
that's the whole point
and
does a platform make users lives better
no
I mean it doesn't
again like a platform it like
platforms have no intrinsic value the
only purpose of a platform no matter
what kind of platform a platform is only
something that facilitates the delivery
of the thing that actually matters
users don't give a about the
platform I mean they really don't give a
about the platform let's think
about this I mean here there's a train
platform
and uh this looks nice it looks very
nice it's nice and Airy there's lots of
you know it's not claustrophobic it has
you know anyway looks fantastic but with
no passengers or no trains running
through this has zero value
huh we need we need the the point of
this platform is to provide a decent you
know train service that uh you know that
gets you to where you want to be on time
that's that's the point and you don't
have to have fancy platforms to deliver
that if you just uh go go to where uh uh
where my my mother's from actually uh I
had this weird situation I'm half
American so my American mother lives in
Norway and my Norwegian father lived in
the US so anyway but like so if you go
to the US and look at train stations
there this is uh my dad's train station
in Virginia this is what they look like
in the US I don't know if anyone's taken
the train in the US it's hilarious
there's no platform there's no platform
and uh but you know the train is running
and you have to you have to like climb
up the train and it's just like it's
absolutely hilarious and like
accessibility wise a complete disaster
but anyway they have somehow they have a
functioning a functioning train system
um but okay let's see you know we're
talking about like you know we need to
focus on users needs what
which one would you choose
well I would choose the one my train
left from for instance art with so you
know again like this is you know I'm not
gonna go to some fancy platform if my
train goes from somewhere completely
different yeah again the point of the
platform is to you know let me get on
the train that takes me where I want to
go that's the point huh so that's the
most that's one of the most important
things
also the closest one
I'm not going to go out of my way
to visit like a fancy platform you know
I'm gonna I'm gonna go to the one that's
closest to me every time
also the cheapest one
and this goes for you know ticket prices
but also just um you know like uh like
in the US they obviously they they maybe
they have better things to do with their
money they have some weapons to buy I
don't know I mean they have they have
other other priorities and you know and
that's fair I'm not saying the American
priorities are correct here but uh but
you know the point is that you know how
much are you gonna how much are you
willing to invest in that platform you
know you have to you have to have quite
a bit of use to the platform before like
a fancy one will ever kind of pay off
yeah again the one with the shortest
train ride I mean I'm not saying that
the cheaper one is always the best one
but the point is that the the only way
that the more kind of fancy platform
even makes sense to make is if it
facilitates the delivery of these
attributes that actually matter to me
you know I I want an efficient way to
get a train that gets me where I'm going
yeah that is the important thing to
focus on
so again the users they don't give a
about the platform that is not the
point and the same goes for software of
course
like everywhere uh lately at least where
I've been working everyone has Office
365 for instance which is a you know a
kind of a platform I guess
um it gives you
um you know Outlook and word
Excel teams all of these applications
but of course we still use slack right
because slack is better than teams we
don't care that slack isn't part of the
platform who gives a you know we
want a good user experience you know we
don't care we don't care about the
platform
you know this is just such a you know so
many people are like well the users they
want everything on one platform no they
don't the users I mean yeah if they can
get maximum you know usability sure and
it also is in the same platform as the
rest yeah great but the most important
thing is the usability
not the platform the users don't give a
about the platform and API users of
course are exactly the same
as a developer
let's say I am you know making some
application
and it has to do with some kind of
finances or whatever and uh and and my
organization has a platform a unified
soap platform say with uh you know where
I can send emails and surveys and
billing and timesheets I know I'm just
you know random example yeah but then I
discovered that hang on a second you
know there are some actual there's a
really good rest based uh email service
that I can use that is actually you know
way more convenient
um you know and then maybe some graphql
service that gives me much nicer surveys
of I'm gonna use them of course I'm
going to use them you know I'm not going
to go oh yes but it's not on the
platform you know like no of course as a
developer just like as any end user
I'm gonna choose the what the services
and the apis that are the easiest and
most convenient to use I don't care if
it's on the platform I mean the point is
the point is ease of use
so um yeah I'm gonna I'm gonna use those
every time
you know and again like people keep
telling me they have it like but the
users don't want to have so many
different applications they don't want
to have they want things uh they want a
unified thing yep what no
this is obvious so many people
seem to somehow believe this but like
come on guys yeah and and again one of
those applications is Chrome you know
and when you open that you will have a
whole list of tabs with all sorts of
different things in there I mean and try
to imagine you know one application that
has all the functionality available on
those uh on those applications it's not
possible I mean you no matter how you
deliver this you're gonna have to split
it into smaller bits you know and and
you will just you will never have
everything on one platform anyway you
know so we really need to at least from
the outset just just know that you will
never have this all-encompassing
platform for everything this is never
gonna happen you know so if we can at
least start by acknowledging that that
would be a big help you will be using
other apis and platforms and and
whatever that is just a given you will
never have everything on one platform
and I think a much better way to kind of
think of what like a platform what what
that really is you know a platform is
basically it is a set of tools then an
I.T organization makes for itself so I
I'm married to a mechanical engineer so
I'm always like I I think it's
fascinating to see kind of the
differences and and similarities of how
how I work compared to uh how my husband
works so he is a he does prototyping a
lot so he's making products he's like
I'm making digital products and he's
making uh he makes um you know things
out of metal and whatever and our our
Workshop is just full of tools you know
that's his platform here here is a
picture of um of uh one of the things he
made recently I I can't remember what
this is I think it's part for some truck
or something but the point is he has
here this is a really cool 3D yeah no
three three axis milling machine
um and you know for for that to work he
then has to make tools like fixtures to
you know affix the things that he's
making so so he is all and this is kind
of this is his platform and he is always
just like we are writing scripts to help
ourselves with you know making the
builds more efficient you know he is
making physical things you know to help
him so the majority of the staff you
know that he works with is actually
tooling for himself you know he is
working on his platform you know just
like we are and again we we of course
also need to have really good tools
um and uh you know and we need to work
on that but the point is at least in
when people are making physical things I
think the people that are buying his
Services they have a better grasp of of
what it is they're buying I think which
makes them take more sensible decisions
because they you know in this case they
are only paying for this part here
they don't pay for him to spend 10 years
building up his platform you know of
course not because that would be stupid
yeah so I mean it makes sense for any
organization that is building anything
at all you know you need to have an
organized toolkit you know no one can
work like this you know we need to
invest significant amounts of time in
building up our platform or our toolkit
you know that is that you know obviously
yeah we need to have an organized set of
tools that lets us work efficiently but
again like we don't pay for the
electrician or a joiner or plumber to
organize her toolkit yeah you know I
don't have to invest in my plumber
getting a pickup truck or something you
know that is something I take as a given
that well yeah I assume that you have
the tools required I'm not going to
invest in in the plumber you know
spending years and years and years
building up some kind of tool and then
finally maybe if I'm lucky they're going
to deliver some kind of plumbing system
that might work you know because that
just would not make sense for me to
invest in that
but somehow and I think it's because the
people buying our services maybe they
just aren't quite aware of how software
works you know so so we're like getting
away with this you know and no wonder
you know we're not complaining you know
because we get to work on platforms and
make like oh yes I get to work on Kafka
and I'll get to do this and this is
we're we're having a we're having a ball
but honestly we shouldn't be getting
away with this I mean we should
definitely be working on improving our
toolkit but it should be in conjunction
with delivering something that actually
matters to people and we actually can do
this too
and I think that one of the reasons that
we are getting away with this is because
again people you know software is a new
field and the people in charge of
budgets and making decisions they are
used to this idea of of these like
physical you know construction projects
like here you know back to trains again
I mean this is a project in Germany at
the moment the Stuttgart I think they're
making this new uh new um train station
there you know and here is the plan of
what they're going to be building and
they have obviously invested vast amount
of time and money and trying to make
this into reality and of course if you
are building this
you know you can't have a running train
service while you're building this thing
I mean at the moment this is 30 years
later and 10 billion years later it
still looks like this and obviously you
know when you are building things in the
physical world
you have to you you know you just have
to yeah drug yourself on opium and just
like hope that you know eventually
you're gonna get something that you can
use right because you you can't have you
can't deliver value as you're building
yeah and you have to you know you have
to think in a completely different way
but we don't have those constraints and
software you know and I think that you
know again the decision makers aren't
fully aware of just how different and
just exactly what we were making I mean
we are making virtual things we're
writing texts basically it's super easy
for us to we can just delete stuff and
add stuff and we can we can change
things as we go along we can start off
you know just making some kind of simple
thing and then we can expand on it over
time we don't have to you know build you
know first this foundation and then the
platform and then finally 10 years later
boom here you go and then if we find out
it doesn't work I mean there's no need
for us to operate like this you know yet
we still are I mean here this is um this
is an old article by now but you know
like uh the NHS you know they try to you
know put out the tender this like big
Health I.T platform thing and you know
10 billion pounds later it was a you
know a complete Fiasco and this just
came out in the US they've spent 50 80
billion dollars
trying to customize some healthcare
platform to suit the the veterans
medical needs you know it's just
absolutely 50 billion and they're not
you know and they haven't actually
delivered a functioning system
I think in public sector of course is is
the worst of these over overspends
um but the private sector too I mean
here little they recently they try to
implement like an sap uh they they spent
like you know half a billion euros in
six seven years and I love this if you
read the small text here it says after a
successful introduction
the the problems piled up and they had
decided to pull the I mean like
what what kind of success what kind of
definition of success is that and I
think the successful part was it cost
half a billion someone made a half a
billion out of this you know that's a
big success after all
um and um you know I think like our
numeric and understanding is a problem
here too because you know here this is a
million versus a billion yeah I mean it
looks you know it doesn't look that
different you know even the words
million billions sounds the same
um but I mean you know that's a million
and it's like a that's a lot more yeah a
million seconds is 11 days
a billion seconds is 31 and a half years
yeah I mean billions into the enormity
of the amounts that we are spending on
these IIT platforms is crazy
yeah and we're spending Millions on user
needs and we're spending billions on
platforms
that's just not right
um and one thing that has struck me and
I haven't been able to really dig in the
numbers because I don't have access to
them but it seems like the the numbers
here are interesting because these
platform failures it's like we're
talking about like billions 10 billion
pounds and you know or 50 billion for
the us thing billions of dollars or
billions of euros
but in Norway our failures cost only 10
billion knock
so we are failing a lot cheaper in
Norway uh
than everywhere else right uh and in
Denmark too I guess I mean it's it's
it's weird but it's not actually weird
if you think about it because you know
in a capitalist system capitalism 101
you don't ask how much is this gonna
cost to make you ask how much are they
willing to pay yeah so like for you know
epic when they are selling in their
Software System to you know one Health
Region in the middle of Norway you know
yeah they of course they can't charge 50
billion dollars
you know but they can charge 6 billion
Kroner which is what they have done you
know so you know and this is kind of
indicative of how you know we all know
that when you're writing software I mean
sure they're they're added costs if
they're 50 million users or 5 million
users yeah there's a bit more cost and
like you need more servers or whatever
to handle the extra load but the
complexity and the domain modeling and
the coding itself it's not really that
much more complicated you know so it's
not you know it's just completely absurd
to uh expect for this to be reasonable
that you know making a computer system
in the UK is somehow you know 50 times
more expensive than making a system in
Norway I mean this is obviously they're
looking at the budgets and they are
charging accordingly
um
so anyway
right so my my message here don't set
out to build a platform
that is not your goal
you need a platform of course you need a
platform and you know by all means have
have this idea that maybe one day
you know we'll have you know we'll have
an amazing platform you know like apple
for instance when they made the first
iPhone they didn't focus on making you
know the App Store and the Apple you
know stuff they focused first and
foremost on making an amazing phone
you know and then the platform has grown
over time you know let the platform grow
by all means dream of platforms being
all-encompassing and wonderful and
solving every world we need and nothing
wrong with having big Ambitions but you
know don't let that happen as a
byproduct of delivering what actually
matters
I think gaul's law is a fantastic in
this respect goals law states
a complex system that works is
invariably found to have evolved from a
simple system that worked
the inverse proposition also appears to
be true a complex system designed from
scratch never works and cannot be made
to work you have to start over beginning
with a simple system
and I think this is uh Yep this this is
true you know you have to start start
with something simple and being software
developers making things in the you know
virtual space we can really do this we
can start simple and we can evolve it
over time there's no reason for us to
not really follow this completely is if
you start
trying to go I will we need to make a
platform for everyone you know you go
immediately you go into people's front
of Judea mode oh this calls for
immediate discussion you know and then
nothing happens for years
you know if anyone followed me on
Twitter a few years ago you'd have heard
me ranting excessively about this
Norwegian Healthcare project that
thankfully has been canceled yes uh it
was called
Exxon that's that's how it's spelled in
Norwegian
um and they'd spent like 10 years and um
you know in people's front of Judy mode
you know planning planning and talking
to everyone and you know making uh you
know trying to figure out what you know
what what was needed you know to solve
basically you know Health Care software
because I mean yeah that's that's just
one thing that you can solve anyway
um so a lot lots of people me included
were very concerned like this these
kinds of you know because what they what
they came up with at the end was we need
to we're going to spend 10 years ish uh
and about like 10 11 billion knock and
developing a platform uh and then we're
gonna spend an additional kind of maybe
you know 10 11 billion knock on
Implement on introducing it and and
everyone's like this kind of 10-year
multi-billion thing typically goes to
you know we this is this is not a
good idea so they they hosted the People
In Charge they had they had a meeting
actually where they were gonna lay
everyone's fears and say no no no no
it's okay we've thought about things uh
here's our plan you know so I I I went
there and I you know again I I'd like
exposing myself to views that I you know
I won't necessarily that I don't think
I'll agree with but I think it's
important to understand where everyone's
coming from so I went try to keep an
open mind like okay what what is their
plan what you know they've they've got
some people to think that you know 22
billion on this thing is a good
investment let's hear them out there
they must have a good elevator pitch
uh and here is I have uh uh I I took
some pictures while I was there and I've
recreated some of the slides that was
presented and here was there this was
their proposal
so uh 10 billion uh or 22 billion in
total would give us a foundation
and uh and and then a platform on top of
that
and on top of that it would be flowers
okay what does that even mean
uh okay and then uh people have been uh
complaining that you know well why don't
we split it up into smaller bits and
they're like of course we're going to
split it up in smaller bits here we're
first we're gonna do step one
and then step two followed by step three
step four anything
foreign
I'm endlessly fascinated because like
you keep hearing you know I showed you
news articles of all these failures
before like 50 billion dollars in the US
and 10 billion in the UK and whatever
um how do these decisions get made in
the first place you know why on Earth do
people decide yes we too shall try to
implement epic it has failed everywhere
but we too shall do it I just I'm I'm
endlessly how how does this come across
as a good idea you know how do you look
at these vague pictures here and and
they're like oh shut up and take my
money oh this looks amazing I would love
nothing more than a foundation with a
platform and then flowers on top you
know that's uh you know I I I you know
this is a perspective that I I
completely lack you know so if anyone
can invite me into one of those meetings
I would love to see how that happens
because uh yeah anyway
um at least you know in in the Physical
Realm I mean here the investment that
they're making there at least you have
an idea of what you're getting
you have an idea of what you're getting
and you say this looks amazing and we
can clearly see that our train system
today is not working and blah blah blah
you can you have some kind of idea of
where you're going you know with these
software platforms
I think the people who are making the
decisions to buy them and to fund them
they don't even know what they're
getting you know this is
again don't build a platform and I need
to stop talking you know I guess you
guys are mostly developers I I need to
find a stage where I can talk to the
decision makers because I mean they are
the ones who really need to understand
us I mean that you know you really yeah
this has to stop you need to organize
your work around what the users need
because that's the point
the platform we are the ones who want
and need the platform not the users
so again like we do need a platform
that's that yeah we
it's not wrong for us to focus on the
platform but we just need to do it in a
sensible way and the way that we most
the reason why these platforms so often
fail
is over generalization
you know we get you know completely you
know the wrong abstractions and the
wrong organization of how things are you
know because typically what the starting
point
uh of you know all we need a new
platform is you have maybe you have a
large corporation they've maybe acquired
other you know companies along the way
you have this large portfolio with lots
of different applications and everyone
is implemented in in its own way and and
it's a mess right
and then the first and worst kind of
over generalization that people can do
and I'm sure that you know I don't know
I know I've uh had this thought and uh
and um seems to happen a lot as people
people start thinking hang on a second
all the all of these applications all
they ever really do is they you know
they they just they create data and then
they you can read the data back again
and then you can update it and then you
can delete it again let's make a correct
platform yes uh and you know so many of
these like no code platforms they fall
into this this kind of trap and uh
and
and it's like I I've I've written stuff
like this myself I've made stuff like
this myself you know so I in a way I
shouldn't judge you know because it's
easy to kind of think that you're being
really smart and you're making this like
generic thing but but of course I mean
this is this is as dumb as looking at
journalists and saying huh all of these
people are all just writing their own
texts all texts it's just words and
sentences Let's Make a sentence platform
you know where where they can pick
sentences from drop down menus and it's
going to be amazing no I mean there are
some Niche areas you know where kind of
no code Solutions like this and having
pre-made templates make sense but these
things are you know notoriously you know
they can work for you know maybe 50 of
the cases they work fantastically and
then they completely fail to handle
anything resembling a corner case you
know this is uh yeah every time uh so
don't do this and um another kind of
more common
um way of failing at least that you know
us Developers are involved in is this
kind of thinking you know you start you
know you look at the these all these
applications that you have and you say
well you know what every one of these
has some kind of security needs
um they all have like front-end
components and stuff they all have like
domain models and and they all have this
you know why don't we make a platform
where we just have one kind of security
thing and then we have one you know we
have we group all our you know
persistence things are here and then we
group all the messages and thing over
here and and yes and then when you're
making an application then then you can
just like use the apis for all of this
and you'll be fine
and the problem with this kind of
organization
is that each of these blocks security or
you know front-end modules or business
rules the main model you know they don't
provide value on their own
they don't you know you you know can the
user test it you know you've updated
some security feature can the user test
it no I mean security only gives value
in a context of some kind of application
right uh messaging stuff it only
provides value if there's someone
messaging someone else I mean you need
the context of the user full application
thing for it to uh for it to have any
value you know can the buyer evaluate
whether it works you know this is also
you know genius thing about the platform
development this way it means that you
the customer who's funding this is
physically it's impossible for them to
evaluate whether any of it works until
it's all done yeah by which time we've
made billions so we're happy uh but this
is uh this is uh not good if you want to
make sure that you're always delivering
what the users actually need and again
here I love how so many of these
platform things are like oh yeah we're
agile we have autonomous teams and it's
like it doesn't matter you can you can't
have a to me if what you are delivering
has no intrinsic value on its own you
can have you can have like 5 000
deployments a day on your you know
security module or whatever but uh if if
no one can actually check that it works
in context that that has no value at all
and what always happens in these
situations when you start off grouping
things like this you know you might
start off when you finally can finish
the platform and you're ready
when you start actually using it and the
user's actual needs start appearing
because you know what the users need is
always really messy and it never falls
into the generalizations and the
categories that you've made there's
always all of these like oh no oh
yeah this is true for that case I know
you know and you end up with every one
of these things bloating bloating
bloating with more and more like oh well
if a and b but l c or if not oh you know
like millions of parameters that you
need to supply where your part only
needs a couple you know but you need to
supply everything because you know it's
this common thing that it needs to
handle every case and for everything you
add here it becomes more and more scary
to update it because you know if I
change something here potentially I'm
gonna you know mess things up for
everyone else and and everything just
slowly grinds to Halt and this and I
think the main problem with this
organization this way of organizing
things is the need for communication
across teams because that is the killer
if you want to be if you want to be able
to respond to your users needs
you you want to minimize the amount of
inter-team communication required to you
know make that change I mean just like
simple kind of graph Theory here I mean
if you have you know two nodes there's
one Edge so communication between two
teams that's fine you know then you know
that can happen reasonably efficiently
but if you add one more boom you have
two more edges you know you add one more
three more edges one more excellent this
is not a linear increase you know the
more teams that deliver something or
that are necessary for for providing
value to the users the more you know the
more communication chaos there is
and the sad thing is that um you know
this our starting point you know where
you have lots of applications and
everyone does their own thing I mean
it's perfectly legitimate to want to
tidy this up by the way again if you
have you know large organization and
your development team uh maybe they
aren't working on like B for years you
know if they then come back to do
something on B and then the tech stack
there is completely incomprehensible and
no one knows how to work how it works
you know that's unfortunate you know so
you should totally look for ways of
standardizing you know that's part of
tidying up your toolkit but you mustn't
lose track of the fact that this way of
organizing stuff where every kind of
every user-focused application has its
own Tech stack and its own team that
that focuses on that I mean there
there's zero communication needs there
is nothing more efficient than that
there's nothing more efficient than that
if someone comes in and says I need you
to change this boom you can change it
and you can deploy it and you don't have
to worry that you've missed any nothing
up for anything else there is nothing
more efficient than or than organizing
stuff like this
um and of course if you have to do this
via you know updating a platform all of
a sudden you're up to like 15 different
communication paths and all of it you
know potentially will impact you
so again like developing software should
be like this can you add a field for
handling this sure you know that that's
what we should aim for right if our
focus is to deliver value to people it
should be this it should be as simple as
possible to just do that
when you're in this platform context you
know yeah team a they're like yeah we
need an input field then you're like oh
no sorry we're working on something for
B right now
fantastic you know then yeah there's oh
no no we we can't actually do that
because that will ruin things for you
know Z over here like oh
and then when you finally found a way
okay right we found a way to organize
stuff so we haven't messed up for Z and
the security team has a time to
implement our change
um and then we roll it out and then it
doesn't work then it's like oh well
where is the error is it and is it in my
code is in their code is in there and
then finally you're like oh did you say
uppercase I thought you meant lowercase
you know oh no okay all right you know
and then you deploy again
uh and then it still doesn't work and
they're like oh and then they're like oh
did you see the QA environment we rolled
it out in the test environment you know
and everyone knows here this is what
takes time and this is what stops up and
halts progress you know all this
incessant you know when you need to
coordinate efforts and understanding
across teams who have their own
priorities this becomes a nightmare and
if you even manage to get something that
then works for your application then you
have to you know make sure that you
haven't broken anything for anyone else
everything grinds to a halt
and then you start working on the new
platform because you can't work with
this let's start a new one right
every time
I've seen this for 20 years now I'm fed
up
um again we need to this I think is just
a much better metaphor for what we need
to think about when we talk about
platforms
our platform
should be just lots of simple opt-in
tools that we can use it's not this
thing it's just a collection of useful
things
um that you can pick and choose
according to your needs
so I mean if this is your starting point
you know you can say that okay well hang
on here we see that these two actually
are the same
yeah we've used the same mechanism two
places right
and here too ah both of these they both
use Kafka say for instance and they both
they're both happy with that great let's
pull that out into our platform our
toolkit let's pull those things into our
toolkit and then the toolkit then
becomes lots of small opt-in components
and no no if else you know no big
monstrosity complex things that everyone
has to use you can have you can have
several types of the same thing and you
can just say well if you um and if your
front end is view here are some view
components if your front end is react
you know here's some react things that's
fine you know you don't have to have
everything doesn't have to be this one
thing you can have small useful
stable things that you can trust
and uh yeah again like reuse here this
these tools here are the kind of
reusability we want to look for you know
really small dedicated simple solid
things you can trust you don't want this
one tool that does everything in the
whole world I mean this one you can buy
it costs a thousand dollars
uh you know this is the kind of thing
that we are all too often making when
we're making these platforms we're like
oh we want this big flexible thing and
it's like no this is totally unusable
you know you want to have small simple
solid things that you can trust and you
can have lots of them that's fine you
know and you pick the one that you need
for your job
and again for the platform components
here it's really useful if the common
things if all the teams your teams
should be dedicated to user needs and
then the common things
everyone should have access to them
where possible where that you know where
at all possible that is a great benefit
because that means that if I as you know
on team a if I need to update you know
something and uh and uh there's some
kind of persistence Library whatever or
service I can just go in and do that
I can do that when I need to I don't
have to sit and wait for you know some
platform team to have time for me you
know and then hopefully manage to convey
my needs in a way that they implemented
correctly uh I can actually just go and
do what I need to have done and by all
means then have code reviews and stuff
but if there's communal kind of
ownership and access to the communal
things that has uh that makes it more
effective and more efficient but also it
increases it it causes alignment
automatically you know everyone
automatically gets familiar with how
things can be done and you learn from
each other so this is just much more
efficient and again wherever you can to
facilitate this TR if your platform
consists of you know useful compile time
libraries makes this a lot simpler you
know if you are you know sharing common
kind of libraries then I can go in and I
can update whatever I need I can bump
the version I can let everyone know say
hey there's a new version of this I've
added this thing then I can deploy you
know the thing I'm working on without
worrying about having destroyed anything
for anyone else so I can safely you know
I can test my part I can roll it out
um and then the other teams they can
take that in they can update the version
and on their side when they have time
and then they can test that their stuff
still works and then they can roll it
out and that way you have a safe way of
rolling out stuff and updating it
without having to have a situation where
you know you're worried about oh no but
what if I change this I might break
everyone else's stuff you know because
that is a real killer if people are
worried about that that's going to stop
your progress immensely and if you have
if you're depending on like these common
running Services you know then you meet
that kind of problem a lot more and you
have to think about all the inversion
you know URLs and and uh all this kind
of stuff so I mean where you can having
a kind of platform toolkit of of common
libraries is um is preferable so and
again here like application a they use
you know a certain amount of tools and B
they use you know different ones and
that's fine
he knows like you know when when
mechanics are making stuff they're
they're not like oh no I didn't use all
the tools I mean that's like this that's
not an issue you know the point is you
need a tool kit that has you know useful
things that you might need and you don't
have to use them all you know
um and another thing you might not even
want to share code just having good
readme files having regular sessions
where developers talk to each other and
share what they've done and how they've
done it that is can be just as good as
having this like everyone's using the
shame system no I mean people can can
use the same you know way of thinking
about stuff and solve things in similar
ways without actually sharing the code
that is a perfectly reasonable thing to
aim for as well
so again what you want you don't want
you don't want you don't want this like
big platform that you know everyone is
plugging into you want every you know
teams dedicated to use cases and then
they take things out of the platform and
they then have responsibility for how
they you know how they use the platform
component that's what you should aim for
and this is uh you know so here you're
getting the ReUse and the you know
simplification and the standardization
that you need but in a much more
sensible way
so um or yeah or more flexible way this
also means that
instead of instead of having a you know
a platform that slowly grinds to a halt
and then you start with a new platform
because the other one obviously doesn't
work anymore you know this way of doing
stuff means that um it's much easier if
you are making a new part or you're
updating some application and you notice
you know what this you know messaging
system isn't working for me you know
it's easy for you can just do something
completely different you can add your
own thing and then once that is
successful then you can add that back to
the platform and then maybe over time
everyone else will say you know what
yeah that's better for me too and then
they will gradually start adopting what
you did and use then reuse you know so
this way of doing stuff means that yeah
you're still always working on your
platform because you know you you need
to work on you know having a good
toolkit that is essential you know not
against platforms as such as just how we
do it you know we need to be working on
having a good toolkit but this way of
working means we can do that while
delivering value
and I have a few minutes left
so I have to just say a few words
um about Cloud because that is uh so
many of us now that is the new
initiative right that's why we need a
new platform because we need to go to
the cloud and this might be a really
good idea but there are issues about
this that I think need to be discussed
more because the thought and the sales
pitch for going to the cloud is that it
is much more efficient that you have you
know obviously your scaling needs are
handled
um and you don't have to you know spend
lots of time and money and effort on
your own data center right that's that's
the point right that you're kind of
delegating that to you know experts like
you know Google and Amazon and Microsoft
um but here this is here's a really
interesting article the cost of cloud a
trillion dollar Paradox where they've
they've looked at lots of you know large
uh systems or large companies Dropbox is
one of them that's profiled and how how
their Cloud Solutions have worked and
here you can see blue lines that is
spending on on-prem Solutions it's like
data center costs and stuff like that
you know and I and then the orange that
is you know what we're spending on cloud
and as you can see we're not actually
spending Less on on-prem Solutions we're
not spending Less on data center if
anything it's actually going up but we
are also spending lots on cloud
and for companies that have you know
large stable workloads and already have
you know their own kind of
infrastructure you know sorted out
like Dropbox is a one of the featured uh
companies they have chosen to repatriate
you know their stuff off the cloud they
want cloud and then they've said you
know what we're just going to bring it
back on-prem again and they have seen
and that this has been for lots of these
companies repatriation results in a
third
to a half
the cost of running the equivalent
workloads in the cloud so they're
they're spending you know they're
spending like three times as much in the
cloud
that I mean if you have so I'm not
saying don't go to the cloud but I'm
saying if you already if you already
have an office Department you already
have the servers and you already are
handling the loads that you need you
know maybe you should be you know
considering this anyway and uh very
often I found I was discussing this on
Twitter
um like why do we why do we want to use
cloud and I think the main reason for us
developers if we're talking about our
incentives here you know we love Cloud
because then we don't have to submit
tickets to the office department to get
anything done we can just like we can
just provision stuff ourselves yes you
know but if this is the reason for going
to the cloud you might consider maybe
finding ways of facilitating better you
know uh collaboration between your
developers and your office Department
you know that that might be a much more
cost effective solution so again I think
cloud fantastic
um but think about this you know this is
you know people are saving tooth you
know they're they're reducing their
costs by two-thirds by repatriation so
that should tell you something so you
know again and finally do the users care
if you're running on the cloud no of
course not they don't care and do the
users care if your apis are soap or rest
no of course not
you know do the users care if your front
end is like JSP or react no they don't
give a
you know we need to start caring about
what the users actually need and want
that's what we should be focusing on you
know what a success this
happy enthusiastic users that's what we
should be aiming for we should be
exposing ourselves to the people that we
are making solutions for and making sure
that we are indeed improving their lives
because that is the point of making
software in the first place right thanks
for listening
[Applause]